This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's hard to overstate just how important record album art was to music before we downloaded everything. Our experience with a record or CD used to be visual. The design of the record cover was your first impression of what was to come. I would stare at the fonts on the cover and pour over the liner notes the first time I put an album on, it was original. I'm not saying that era music was better, it wasn't, it was just different. The art on the records tried to encapsulate
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯。在一切都可以下载之前，唱片封套对音乐的重要性怎么强调都不为过。我们对唱片或CD的体验曾经是视觉上的。唱片封套的设计是你对即将听到的内容的第一印象。我第一次放一张唱片时，会盯着封面上的字体，仔细研读内页说明，那是一种独特的体验。我并不是说那个时代的音乐更好，并非如此，只是它与众不同。唱片上的艺术试图概括
the essence of a band, and then that essence was transferred to you because you were a fan, and it became part of your identity too. At least that's what it felt like. Album art was certainly important to my friend and reporter, Sean Cole, one certain album and one certain band in particular. Roman were you ever a Divo fan?
乐队的精髓，然后这种精髓会传递给你，因为你是粉丝，它也成为了你身份的一部分。至少感觉是这样。对于我的朋友兼记者肖恩·科尔来说，唱片封套无疑很重要，尤其是某张特定的唱片和某支特定的乐队。罗曼，你曾经是De-vo的粉丝吗？
I was a more of a Divo appreciator, I don't think I was really a fan. Like I listened to unlike the songs I heard, I remember Whip It when I was a kid, I remember they were. You were not a Divo team. No, it was not a Divo team. I remember the red hats and I have a particular memory of them doing a cover of I can't get no satisfaction by the rolling stones on starting at live when these yellow hazmat suits. You know, like they were really weird.
我更多是De-vo的欣赏者，我觉得算不上真正的粉丝。就像我听过我不喜欢的歌，我记得小时候听过《Whip It》，我记得他们……你不是De-vo的铁粉。不，我不是De-vo的铁粉。我记得那些红色的帽子，我特别记得他们在《周六夜现场》上翻唱滚石乐队的《(I Can't Get No) Satisfaction》，当时穿着黄色的防化服。你知道，他们真的很怪。
Yes, weird. Yes. So this story is about that divot album, the one that they were promoting on that Sarnight Live performance you saw. More specifically, it's about the album art of that record. Because the story of the image that ultimately ended up on the cover of that record is this crazy rabbit hole that I fell down. But before we get there, I just need to cover some things about Divo that you might not know. Do you know where the name comes from?
是的，怪。没错。所以这个故事就是关于那张De-vo专辑，就是你在那场《周六夜现场》表演中看到的他们正在宣传的那张。更具体地说，是关于那张唱片的封面艺术。因为最终出现在那张唱片封面上的图像背后的故事，是我陷入的一个疯狂的兔子洞。但在进入正题之前，我需要先介绍一些你可能不知道的关于De-vo的事情。你知道这个名字的由来吗？
I do not. So, a lot of people think of diva as this really silly, you know, nutty e-band and jumping around, but they were actually very serious and had a very considered philosophy. And that was that the human race is in a state of de-evolution, hence divo. So their songs are all, you know, other than Whip It, like their songs are mostly about corporate control and blind conformity, and they were actually visual artists before they wrote any songs.
我不知道。很多人认为De-vo是一支非常傻、非常疯狂的乐队，蹦蹦跳跳的，但他们实际上非常严肃，有着非常深思熟虑的哲学。那就是人类正处于“去进化”（de-evolution）的状态，因此叫De-vo。所以他们的歌，除了《Whip It》之外，大多是关于企业控制和盲目顺从的，而且他们在写歌之前实际上是视觉艺术家。
This was in the early 70s in Akron, Ohio. So I talked with one of the founders of Devo, Jerry Kasale, who says like back then, they were mostly trying to figure out what de-evolutionary art would look like. You know, because we were very enamored and put off at the same time by pop culture, like the lowest end of like ad graphics, terrible TV commercials. We were kind of drawn to Kitch, and occasionally they would go out shopping for Kitch. So we're walking through the Kmart.
那是70年代初在俄亥俄州的阿克伦。所以我采访了De-vo的创始人之一杰里·卡萨莱，他说当时他们主要是在试图弄清楚“去进化艺术”会是什么样子。你知道，因为我们既迷恋又反感流行文化，比如最底层的广告图形、糟糕的电视广告。我们被媚俗（Kitsch）所吸引，偶尔他们会出去寻找媚俗的东西。所以我们走在Kmart里。
Nope, it was the predecessor to Kmart. It was click. And this is Mark Mothersburg, he's another member of the band. This is probably the point to mention that this was more than four decades ago and not everybody's memory is too clear. So the independent of what department store they are in. They are in a department store. They are in a department store. We were looking for supplies.
不，那是Kmart的前身。是Click。这是马克·马瑟斯博，他是乐队的另一名成员。现在大概应该提一下，这是四十多年前的事了，并不是每个人的记忆都那么清晰。所以不管他们在哪个百货公司。他们在百货公司。他们在百货公司。我们在寻找补给品。
We were collaborating on a visual art piece together and walking through the sports section. And there's these six practice golf balls in a clear plastic pouch sealed shut at the top with a cardboard display head. Took a new picture of this, it's like that display head with the hole in it that hangs on a hook. Yes, I can picture it. Kind of like the rocks with bags of generic candy at the gas station, like a clear bag full of candy and it just says gummy bears at the top. Alright, so on that display head is an illustration of the smiling face of Chichi Rodriguez.
我们当时正在合作一件视觉艺术作品，走在体育用品区。那里有六个练习高尔夫球，装在一个透明塑料袋里，顶部用纸板展示头封口。拍了一张这个的新照片，就像那个带孔的展示头，挂在钩子上。是的，我能想象出来。有点像加油站里装普通糖果的袋子，就像一个装满糖果的透明袋子，上面写着“小熊软糖”。好吧，那个展示头上是奇奇·罗德里格斯的笑脸插图。
And who was Chichi Rodriguez? Chichi Rodriguez is one of the most famous golfers in history. He was like, I don't know what Chichi Rodriguez was like. He was like the Elvis of golfer. So he was just like a big show, man. I saw it and I just loved it. It was a picture of him in front of a golf ball. So his head's kind of haloed by a big golf ball.
奇奇·罗德里格斯是谁？奇奇·罗德里格斯是历史上最著名的高尔夫球手之一。他就像是……我不知道奇奇·罗德里格斯是什么样的。他就像高尔夫球界的猫王。所以他就是一个大表演家。我看到了，我就是喜欢它。那是一张他在高尔夫球前的照片。所以他的头被一个大高尔夫球衬托得像有光环一样。
Kind of imitating something that I'd already been printing, which was human heads in front of the moon, and it made us laugh. We chuckle. We have to have that. And of course golf was almost symbolically like the most lame kind of, you know, bourgeois pursuit that you could have,
有点模仿我已经在印刷的东西，也就是人头在月亮前面，这让我们笑了。我们咯咯笑。我们必须拥有它。当然，高尔夫在象征意义上几乎是最蹩脚的、你知道的、资产阶级的追求，
especially at that time, unless your parents were rich, you didn't get to go golfing. If we ever imagined ourselves on a golf course, it was probably as a caddy. And how boring it looked then on TV and then announcing, but the one guy who stood out was Chi Chi because he didn't fit with the rest of the golfers at all. He wore these loud pants and bright shirts and he had this famous hat that only he wore which had a specific hat band and you know, the Panama hat.
尤其是在那个时候，除非你父母很有钱，否则你没机会去打高尔夫。如果我们曾经想象自己在高尔夫球场上，那可能也是作为球童。当时在电视上看到它有多无聊，然后是解说，但唯一突出的那个人是奇奇，因为他根本不适合其他高尔夫球手。他穿着花哨的裤子和鲜艳的衬衫，他戴着那顶只有他才戴的著名帽子，有特定的帽带，你知道，巴拿马帽。
Straw Panama kind of hat, yeah. So did they buy those golf balls? They bought the golf balls. Mark used the Chi Chi image in a manifesto he was writing about being a quote unquote, Spud Boy in the rubber town of Akron. But other than that, nothing really happened with it
草编巴拿马那种帽子，是的。所以他们买了那些高尔夫球吗？他们买了高尔夫球。马克在他写的一篇关于在阿克伦橡胶城做一个所谓的“土豆男孩”（Spud Boy）的宣言中使用了奇奇的形象。但除此之外，并没有发生什么
until we were already putting out our self-produced single, Be Stiff. Oh, I like that song. It's, this is my favorite one. So it's like this kind of jockey anthem, celebrating literal stiffness, like uptightness, talking about televangelist, politicians, and how stiff they are. Somehow, and I don't really remember the moment, but we had the idea of putting chichi on that cover.
直到我们已经准备发行我们自制的单曲《Be Stiff》。哦，我喜欢那首歌。这是我最喜欢的一首。所以这是一种类似骑师的赞歌，庆祝字面意义上的僵硬，比如紧张，谈论电视布道者、政客，以及他们有多僵硬。不知何故，我不记得那一刻了，但我们有了把奇奇放在封面上的想法。
And so they used that picture of chichi on the cover of the 45 of the single. And it was like this commentary on commercialism and our obsession with selling. And in this case, selling plastic golf balls It was like this commentary on commercialism and our obsession with selling. In this case, selling plastic golf balls and the Americana of the golfer. So B-Step comes out in 1978 and there's still not famous. They're in the Subscure Art Rock Band.
于是他们把那张奇奇的照片用在了单曲的45转唱片封面上。这就像是对商业主义和我们对销售的痴迷的评论。在这种情况下，销售塑料高尔夫球，以及高尔夫球手的美国文化。所以《Be Stiff》在1978年发行，他们还不出名。他们是一支默默无闻的艺术摇滚乐队。
But then about four months later, Devo gets their big break. Warner Brothers signed the band to their first full-length album. And that, according to Jerry, is where the real D evolution began. We've laid that whole thing out and working up to this moment, and then comes the real Devo twist that only a corporation could provide. In other words, what we're talking about, we become part of. So there are about to be on top 40 radio and broadcasts on the TV screens of Middle America. What was that first record called? It's a long title. It's called Question. Are we? Question? Are we not men? Answer, we are Devo. And this is their first major label album.
但大约四个月后，De-vo迎来了他们的重大突破。华纳兄弟签下了这支乐队，发行了他们的第一张全长专辑。据杰里说，真正的“去进化”就是从那里开始的。我们已经铺垫了这一切，并为这一刻做准备，然后出现了只有大公司才能提供的真正的De-vo式转折。换句话说，我们所谈论的，我们成为了其中的一部分。所以他们即将出现在40大电台和美国中部的电视屏幕上。那张唱片叫什么名字？名字很长。叫《Question: Are We Not Men? Answer: We Are Devo!》。这是他们第一张大厂牌专辑。
This is their first, yeah, I know exactly right. So Mark and Jerry and the other members of the band, they're like, well, that picture of Chi Chi worked so well on the single, let's just stick with it. You know, it's kind of our brand now. Let's just put that on the cover of the full length record. And this is like a picture of Chishi Rodriguez. The original picture from that thing they bought at Kmart, they just took that, lifted it directly and put it onto their album and they're going to
这是他们的第一张，是的，我知道，没错。所以马克和杰里以及乐队的其他成员，他们想，好吧，那张奇奇的照片在单曲上效果很好，我们就坚持用它吧。你知道，这现在算是我们的品牌了。我们就把它放在全长唱片的封面上。这就像是一张奇奇·罗德里格斯的照片。他们从Kmart买的那东西上的原始照片，他们只是拿过来，直接提取出来，放到了他们的专辑上，他们打算
put that now on a major label album. Okay. So they head to California, you know, movie, montage, theme music here, Beverly Hill Belays, whatever. And they go to Warner Brothers HQ and this is like the process back then. And maybe now I don't know, but like they're heading from department to department and Warner Brothers, you know, dealing with all of the new album things that need to happen. We're told to go see, I think Rick Serini was his name and he seemed to be an okay guy. He's in the art department. Yeah, he's the head of the art department.
现在把它放在大厂牌专辑上。好吧。所以他们前往加利福尼亚，你知道，电影蒙太奇，这里有主题音乐，《贝弗利山庄》什么的。他们去了华纳兄弟总部，这就是当时的流程。也许现在也是，我不知道，但他们从一个部门走到另一个部门，华纳兄弟，你知道，处理所有需要发生的新专辑事情。我们被告知去见，我想他叫里克·塞里尼，他看起来是个不错的人。他在艺术部门。是的，他是艺术部门的负责人。
I was creative director at Warner Bros. Records. He seemed to like what we were up to. The one band that I appreciated the most was Devo. I love the fact that they just never took anything very seriously. Do you remember that first meeting with them? I'm not alone. Do I remember to have a polaroid of it. We show him the image. He chuckles.
我是华纳兄弟唱片的创意总监。他似乎喜欢我们正在做的事情。我最欣赏的一支乐队是De-vo。我喜欢他们从不把任何事情看得太严肃的事实。你还记得第一次见他们吗？我不孤单。我记得我有它的宝丽来照片。我们给他看那张图。他咯咯笑。
I thought it was clip art. Yeah. Chi Chi does look a lot like clip art. And I guess I never asked. I only found out that it was him sometime later. Well, I guess what did it, I guess what did he vote for you? Obserty. I guess what did it, I guess what did it evoke for you? Absurdity.
我以为那是剪贴画。是的，奇奇看起来确实很像剪贴画。我想我从来没问过。我直到后来才知道那是他。好吧，我想是什么，我想是什么让你想到的？荒谬。我想是什么，我想是什么让你想到的？荒谬。
I mean, you have to think about what was going on back in the day. Artwork, you know, on album covers had rules attached to it. Most of the albums were delivered to little mom pop music stores all around the country. Right. And there'd be some kid who would come in at four o'clock after school. And his job was to open up the box of records from Warner Brothers or Columbia or whatnot and then rack them. Right? So the one thing that they told all of us in the art department is don't screw that up. A rock band has to look like a rock band, a country western has to look
我的意思是，你必须考虑当时发生了什么。艺术作品，你知道，在唱片封面上是有规则的。大多数唱片都被送到全国各地的小型音乐商店。对吧。会有个孩子在放学后四点钟进来。他的工作是打开华纳兄弟或哥伦比亚唱片公司之类的唱片箱，然后把它们上架。对吧？所以他们在艺术部门告诉我们所有人的唯一一件事就是不要搞砸了。摇滚乐队必须看起来像摇滚乐队，乡村音乐必须看起来
like country western. They'd better have cowboy hats on. Otherwise, they get misracked. And then if people can't find them in the rack of the genre they're interested in, they don't buy it. But in Devo's case, the music was so unusual that it could have something completely absurd on the cover and make perfect sense. So even though it makes no sense that a picture of a flamboyant golfer stolen from a package of golf balls, yes, is the mascot of Devo. It does make perfect sense because that's who Devo is.
像乡村音乐。他们最好戴着牛仔帽。否则，它们会被放错架子。然后如果人们在他们感兴趣的流派架子上找不到它们，他们就不会买。但在De-vo的例子中，音乐太不寻常了，封面上有完全荒谬的东西也完全说得通。所以即使一个从高尔夫球包装上偷来的华丽高尔夫球手的照片是De-vo的吉祥物，这完全说不通，但它确实完全说得通，因为这就是De-vo。
It was just like pick something impossible and Rick is just psyched. Like he loves working, he loves working on this, loves working on this with them. It's like doing all the little design things and giving them the font with the double bold and all the stuff and getting everything ready. He laid it all out, spec the colors. You know, did the whole series thing where they give you a transparency that's a mockup, right?
这就像选一些不可能的东西，里克非常兴奋。他喜欢工作，他喜欢和他们一起做这个，喜欢和他们一起做这个。这就像做所有的小设计，给他们双粗体字体和所有这些东西，并准备好一切。他把一切都排版好，指定颜色。你知道，做了整个系列，他们给你一个透明胶片作为模型，对吧？
And we approve it. And then about two days later, we get this call and it's a big crisis. The call was from the vice president of Business Affairs for Warner Brothers. David Burman, who was a guy that you would cast in a movie about the music business? As the villain or as the hero? Well, it just depends on your point of view. It was very smart, very good at what he did and played a hard ball.
我们批准了它。然后大约两天后，我们接到了这个电话，这是一个大危机。电话是华纳兄弟商业事务副总裁打来的。大卫·伯曼，一个你会选去演关于音乐产业电影的人？作为反派还是英雄？嗯，这取决于你的观点。他非常聪明，非常擅长他的工作，而且手段强硬。
And the first communication is, I'm a golfer and I'm a fan of golf and I know Chi Chi Rodriguez. I've met Chi Chi Rodriguez. You cannot use Chi Chi Rodriguez. That is completely and totally false. This is David Burman. I told you not everybody's memory is crystal clear regarding this story. Not only have I never, I have never seen Cheachy Rodriguez, other than on television. I'm not going to make fun of a friend of mine.
第一次沟通是，我是个高尔夫球手，我是高尔夫球迷，我认识奇奇·罗德里格斯。我见过奇奇·罗德里格斯。你不能使用奇奇·罗德里格斯。这完全是错误的。这是大卫·伯曼。我告诉过你，并不是每个人的记忆对这个故事都非常清晰。我不但从来没有，我从来没见过奇奇·罗德里格斯，除了在电视上。我不会去取笑我的一个朋友。
I've never met him. I've never spoken to him. I'm not going to get this company sued. That part is accurate, says David Berman, about maybe being sued. Yes, he did play hardball, but he says his objection was purely a legal one. Purely. In California law, it's crystal clear. You can't use somebody's name or likeness for commercial purposes without their permission. He had nothing to do with my being a golfer other than because I was, I knew that it was
我从来没见过他。我从来没跟他说过话。我不会让这家公司被起诉。大卫·伯曼说，关于可能被起诉的那部分是准确的。是的，他确实手段强硬，但他表示他的反对纯粹是法律上的。纯粹是。在加州法律中，这非常明确。未经许可，你不能将某人的姓名或肖像用于商业目的。他和我是一个高尔夫球手没有任何关系，除了因为我是，我知道那是
clearly Cheechy R. R R. Vegas, but it wasn't the fact that he was likeable. It could have been Rory Sabatini and I would have done the same thing. Wait, who is Rory Sabatini? He's a golfer. But nobody likes Rory Sabatini. Why does nobody like Rory Sabatini? I don't know. Also, Rory Sabatini was born in 1976 and would have been two years old when this diva record came out.
显然是奇奇·罗德里格斯，但并不是因为他讨人喜欢。可能是罗里·萨巴蒂尼，我也会做同样的事。等等，罗里·萨巴蒂尼是谁？他是个高尔夫球手。但没人喜欢罗里·萨巴蒂尼。为什么没人喜欢罗里·萨巴蒂尼？我不知道。而且，罗里·萨巴蒂尼出生于1976年，这张De-vo唱片出来时他才两岁。
But anyway, this all came as a real blow to the band. We're dumbfounded and crestfallen. We don't know what to do. And but of course, we're stubborn. We're not giving up. So they're like, let's just write Chi Chi a letter and ask his permission. But in the meantime, the corporate gears are rolling
但无论如何，这对乐队来说是一个真正的打击。我们目瞪口呆，垂头丧气。我们不知道该怎么办。但当然，我们很固执。我们不会放弃。所以他们说，让我们给奇奇写封信请求他的许可。但与此同时，公司的齿轮正在转动，
and money has been paid and, you know, Warner Bros. is expecting a product. So, Divos, like, let's come up with a plan B, and they had this idea that actually involves another piece of D evolutionary art. There's an artist rendering of what the last four presidents would have looked like had you combined them. So Ford, Nixon, Johnson, and Kennedy, all of their faces, mashed together. Mark Mothers' Bud just had this picture lying around.
钱已经付了，你知道，华纳兄弟期待着产品。所以，De-vo想，让我们想个B计划，他们有了这个想法，实际上涉及另一件“去进化”艺术作品。有一张艺术家渲染图，展示了如果把最后四位总统结合起来会是什么样子。所以福特、尼克松、约翰逊和肯尼迪，他们所有的脸，拼凑在一起。马克·马瑟斯博只是随手放着这张照片。
And it was this hideous, bizarre face that had John Kennedy's hairline and it had Lyndon Johnson's ears and Richard Nixon's nose. So the band brings that image to the Warner Brothers Art Department. On an idea that why couldn't we just mutate Chi Chi's face? So that it isn't Chi Chi anymore. So what did they end up doing to Chi Chi's face?
那是一张丑陋、怪异的脸，有约翰·肯尼迪的发际线，有林登·约翰逊的耳朵和理查德·尼克松的鼻子。所以乐队把那张图带到了华纳兄弟艺术部门。基于一个想法，为什么我们不能变异奇奇的脸？这样它就不再是奇奇了。所以他们最终对奇奇的脸做了什么？
So they basically, like, it was like building a Mr. Potato Head toy, like they grafted Johnson's ears and Nixon's nose on the cheeky's head and reverse the mouth. I should actually, I should say that David Berman who was in business affairs at the time, he doesn't remember the image being altered. So I sent him the original cheeky image from the golf balls and the potato head collage just so he could compare them.
所以他们基本上，就像拼装“土豆头先生”玩具一样，他们把约翰逊的耳朵和尼克松的鼻子嫁接到奇奇的头上，并反转了嘴巴。我实际上应该说，当时在商业事务部的大卫·伯曼，他不记得图像被修改过。所以我把高尔夫球上的原始奇奇图像和土豆头拼贴画发给了他，这样他就可以比较它们。
Look me at it today. I wonder why I proved it because to me it still looks like Gigi, but obviously I must have. And here's Jerry Cassali. About three weeks later, a letter comes back from Gigi's representatives. No. Saying, yes, Gigi thinks it's fine to use that image. He just wants 50 records at Christmas time to give out to his friends and family. He wanted to say to his friends and family, like, look, I'm on a record. Right. He liked that.
今天看着它。我想知道我为什么批准它，因为对我来说它看起来仍然像奇奇，但显然我一定批准了。这是杰里·卡萨莱。大约三周后，奇奇的代表回信了。不。说，是的，奇奇认为使用那个形象没问题。他只是想要50张唱片在圣诞节送给他的朋友和家人。他想对他的朋友和家人说，看，我在一张唱片上。对。他喜欢那样。
And this is Mark Mother's Ball. And so at that point, it's like, we couldn't go back. They'd already printed the cover. So now we had this mutilated potato face for an album cover. And it didn't really look like the handsome Chi Chi anymore. So I'm sure he was quite surprised when he got a box of him in the mail. All our efforts were in fact in earnest. But what it looked like in the end is that Devo had mainly tricked Chi Chi Rodriguezai Riegas and put out something that made him look hideous.
这是马克·马瑟斯博。所以在那一点上，就像，我们无法回头了。他们已经印好了封面。所以现在我们有了一张残缺的土豆脸作为专辑封面。它看起来确实不再像英俊的奇奇了。所以我敢肯定，当他收到一箱自己的照片时，他一定很惊讶。我们所有的努力确实是真诚的。但最终看起来像是De-vo主要欺骗了奇奇·罗德里格斯，并发布了一些让他看起来很丑陋的东西。
It was a mess. Now, they did send Chichi a couple thousand dollars also as well as the records. It wasn't a total loss for him, but then they just, they never heard from him again. Wow. So they never got his take on the album art, or even the songs on the album or anything like that? Which is my reigning question in all of this. I really want to know if Chi Chi ever listened to that record
那是一团糟。现在，他们确实也给了奇奇几千美元以及那些唱片。对他来说这不是完全的损失，但后来他们就再也没有收到他的消息了。哇。所以他们从来没有得到他对专辑封面的看法，甚至是对专辑里的歌或类似的东西的看法？这是我在这一切中主要的问题。我真的很想知道奇奇是否听过那张唱片
and what he thought of it. Yeah, that would be the big question. Well, why don't you interview Chi Chi Rodriguez? Hello. Hello, Chi Chi Rodriguez. Yeah, who's this? It's Sean Cole. He reached T.C. at a country club, naturally. In West Palm Beach, Florida, he's in his early 80s now,
以及他对此有什么看法。是的，那会是最大的问题。好吧，你为什么不采访奇奇·罗德里格斯呢？你好。你好，奇奇·罗德里格斯。是的，你是谁？我是肖恩·科尔。他自然是在乡村俱乐部联系到奇奇的。在佛罗里达州西棕榈滩，他现在80多岁了，
still handsome, still plays golf, not professionally. Does a lot of philanthropic work through his foundation and an annual charity event. It's really an honor to talk to you. It's my honor to talk to you, Johnny. It's Sean, but that's okay. Oh, he sounds like the best, Johnny. I love him. He's so sweet. I love him. Chichi says he remembers getting this letter, and he says he did give out those records to his friends and family. Did you notice when you got the record that it didn't quite look like you that much? Well, it looked like me. I look at the process. It looked like me a little bit, at least they had looked like me.
依然英俊，依然打高尔夫球，不是职业的。通过他的基金会和年度慈善活动做了很多慈善工作。真的很荣幸能和你交谈。我也很荣幸能和你交谈，约翰尼。我是肖恩，但没关系。哦，他听起来像个最好的人，约翰尼。我爱他。他太甜了。我爱他。奇奇说他记得收到这封信，他说他确实把那些唱片送给了他的朋友和家人。当你收到唱片时，你有没有注意到它看起来不太像你？嗯，它看起来像我。我看着那个过程。它看起来像我一点点，至少它们看起来像我。
But he didn't know anything about them messing with his face, and he had no idea that they were worried he was going to sue them. Sue them? Well, anybody that worried about somebody suing them, that means that they're so crooked that they sue people and they think that people are going to sue them. Well anybody that worried about somebody soon, that means that they're so crooked that they sue people And they think that people have a sue them. I thought it was this young people trying to make a career out of it And I could help them and that's it because I like I like to do something good every day of my life And I want to leave the the earth better than I found it. So even young sort of avant-garde punk musicians you want to help. Yeah.
但他不知道他们弄乱了他的脸，他根本不知道他们担心他会起诉他们。起诉他们？嗯，任何担心别人起诉他们的人，这意味着他们自己就很狡猾，他们起诉别人，他们认为别人也会起诉他们。嗯，任何担心别人起诉的人，这意味着他们自己就很狡猾，他们起诉别人，他们认为别人也会起诉他们。我以为是这些年轻人想以此为职业，我可以帮助他们，就是这样，因为我喜欢，我喜欢每天做点好事。我想让地球比我发现它时更好。所以即使是年轻的先锋朋克音乐家你也想帮助。是的。
Did you listen to that record? Yeah, I listened to it one time just once. I put her away. You didn't like it. No, I didn't like it. I like Traction Atre and Nath King Cole and Dave Martin, who was my favorite, you know. Because music is not supposed to rally up. Music is something to bring you down.
你听过那张唱片吗？是的，我听过一次，就一次。我把它收起来了。你不喜欢它。不，我不喜欢它。我喜欢特拉奇·阿特雷（Trini Lopez）和纳特·金·科尔（Nat King Cole）和戴夫·马丁（Dean Martin），他是我的最爱，你知道。因为音乐不应该是让人兴奋的。音乐是用来让你平静下来的。
So the most important question answered. He did not like it. Right, and like, but as I was talking to him, I was like, well, there's like a kind of greater question here, which is like, like what did he think about his face or a mutated version thereof, being on the cover of this apocalyptic weirdo art rock bands first record, like did that make sense to him. And it did, in a way, because because Chichi knows he's Chichi. He knows how much he stands out and how
所以最重要的问题得到了回答。他不喜欢它。对，而且，当我跟他交谈时，我在想，嗯，这里有一个更大的问题，就是，他对自己脸的变异版本出现在这个末日怪异艺术摇滚乐队的第一张唱片封面上有什么看法，这对他来说有意义吗？确实有，在某种程度上，因为奇奇知道他是奇奇。他知道他有多突出，以及他有多
it outlandish he is. None of that is lost on him. And in fact, he said it's purposeful. Golf is show business and when you're on stage, you got to give the people a show. And that's what the people came out and gave the people a good time. So that is the similarity between you and Devo? Yes. So in a way, it really makes sense that they used you on the cover of their record. I think they were geniuses.
古怪。这一切他都明白。事实上，他说这是有目的的。高尔夫是演艺事业，当你站在舞台上时，你必须给人们一场表演。这就是人们出来并给人们带来美好时光的原因。所以这就是你和De-vo之间的相似之处？是的。所以从某种意义上说，他们在唱片封面上使用你确实很有道理。我认为他们是天才。
And it takes a genius to recognize another. Hahaha. Hahaha. Hahaha. Hahaha. Wow, you guys sound almost diabolical there. Hahaha. Yes. Me and Chi Chi, the bottom of Ovalcano. Hahaha.
而天才才能识别另一个天才。哈哈哈。哈哈哈。哈哈哈。哈哈哈。哇，你们听起来几乎是邪恶的。哈哈哈。是的。我和奇奇，在火山底部。哈哈哈。
Planning the evolution of the human race. The evolution of the human race, exactly. One could argue that, again, Jerry Cassali, what we were put through by David Berman, actually achieved something here better than just using a found image. So what you're saying is corporate interference plus the faces of four American presidents who prosecuted the Vietnam War, and it's aftermath, and this wonderfully dandy-ish golf legend, all of those together. Yeah, it's more Devo than the original Chichi image in a way. That's what I'm saying.
计划人类的进化。人类的进化，没错。有人可能会争辩说，再次提到杰里·卡萨莱，大卫·伯曼让我们经历的事情实际上在这里取得了一些比仅仅使用现成图像更好的成果。所以你的意思是企业干预加上四位起诉越南战争及其后果的美国总统的脸，以及这位奇妙的、花花公子般的高尔夫传奇，所有这些加在一起。是的，从某种意义上说，它比原始的奇奇图像更De-vo。这就是我想说的。
It's Devo in action. Like, you need an example of what we're talking about? Here it is. So this whole story takes place at the beginning of Debo's career. And they go on to play for decades, it's extremely famous. They were just nominated to be in the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame. Do they think about Chi Chi as part of their origin story?
这是行动中的De-vo。就像，你需要一个我们正在谈论的例子吗？这就是。所以整个故事发生在De-vo职业生涯的开始。他们继续演奏了几十年，非常出名。他们刚刚被提名为摇滚名人堂候选人。他们认为奇奇是他们起源故事的一部分吗？
You know, Mark Mothersbach actually sort of raised that when we were talking. I really, I don't think anybody ever tried to measure how much that album cover had in the success of Divo, but it could possibly have been the tipping stone that just like changed everything and gave us a chance to have a public career. So just in case, thank you, Chi Chi.
你知道，马克·马瑟斯博在我们交谈时实际上提到了这一点。我真的，我不认为有人试图衡量那张专辑封面在De-vo的成功中占了多少，但它可能是一个转折点，改变了一切，给了我们一个拥有公共职业生涯的机会。所以以防万一，谢谢你，奇奇。
Hey, Roman. Yeah. Stories not over. There's one more diabolical divot twist, a year's Dirk Asali. I have to say that now that I'm a senior citizen, I completely changed my attitude about the game of golf. You did not, really? Yeah, I like it now.
嘿，罗曼。是的。故事还没结束。还有一个更邪恶的De-vo式转折，杰里·卡萨莱。我必须说，现在我是一个老年人了，我完全改变了对高尔夫运动的态度。你没有，真的吗？是的，我现在喜欢它了。
I really, it's changed so much from those days and who got to play it and how it's played. I mean, those guys really are athletes. I never thought I would hear a member of D'Avo say that. I mean, those guys really are athletes. I never thought I would hear a member of Devo say that. I know. Oh, here's a, here's a doubly hideous secret on folding right now. I really like professional football. A version of this piece originally aired on the NPR Sports Show only a game, special thanks to Gary Wallach who conceived of the story and Hugh Brown, who helped Sean Cole with the research.
它真的从那些日子里改变了很多，谁能玩它以及它是怎么玩的。我的意思是，那些家伙确实是运动员。我从没想过我会听到De-vo的成员这么说。我的意思是，那些家伙确实是运动员。我从没想过我会听到De-vo的成员这么说。我知道。哦，这里有一个，这里有一个双重丑陋的秘密正在展开。我真的很喜欢职业橄榄球。这个片段的一个版本最初在NPR体育节目《Only A Game》中播出，特别感谢构思这个故事的加里·沃拉赫和帮助肖恩·科尔进行研究的休·布朗。
Around the time Divo was putting out there for singles in the mid-1970s, a music teacher in Canada was making his own DIY records with a bunch of his elementary school students, and the result was a haunting and uplifting outsider or masterpiece. That story. After this. In Canada, in the 1970s, a music teacher named Hans Finger recorded 60 of his elementary school students singing in a gymnasium.
在De-vo在70年代中期发行他们的单曲时，加拿大的一位音乐老师正在和一群小学生制作他自己的DIY唱片，结果是一部令人难忘且振奋人心的局外人艺术杰作。那个故事。之后。在70年代的加拿大，一位名叫汉斯·芬格的音乐老师录制了60名小学生在体育馆唱歌的录音。
He pressed a few vinyl records of those recordings and handed them out to parents. The Langley School Music Project was little known until a record collector named Brian Linde found one of those albums in a thrift store in the year 2000. Linde shared it with some people and eventually bar none records gave it a proper release. The records cover featured a collage of black and white pictures of the students singing, strumming guitars, playing drums, and clapping along. The album was called Innocence and Despair. The rediscovered recordings were a hit. Salon music critic Stephen Heiden wrote, the gloomy title in a sense and despair is no lie. The echoing, yelping renditions of this feel-good music
他压制了几张这些录音的黑胶唱片，并分发给家长。兰利学校音乐项目（Langley School Music Project）鲜为人知，直到一位名叫布莱恩·林德的唱片收藏家在2000年在一家旧货店发现了其中一张专辑。林德与一些人分享了它，最终Bar None唱片公司给了它一个正式的发行。唱片封面是一张黑白照片拼贴画，展示了学生们唱歌、弹吉他、打鼓和拍手。这张专辑叫《Innocence and Despair》。重新发现的录音大受欢迎。Salon音乐评论家斯蒂芬·海登写道，阴郁的标题《Innocence and Despair》并非谎言。这种感觉良好的音乐的回声、尖叫的演绎
gives off a powerfully aching melancholy. It's the sound of youth frozen on tape as it fades inexorably away. Here's the music teacher from the Langley School Music Project Hans Finger talking to Katie Mingle in 2010. Before I was teaching in Langley, I played in a heavy metal band. It never occurred to me to be a teacher. I was a really good student myself and the kids were okay, but I wasn't
散发出一种强烈的痛苦忧郁。这是青春被冻结在磁带上，随着它不可阻挡地消逝的声音。这是来自兰利学校音乐项目的音乐老师汉斯·芬格在2010年与凯蒂·明格尔的谈话。在我在兰利教书之前，我在一支重金属乐队里演奏。我从来没想过要当老师。我自己是个很好的学生，孩子们也还可以，但我并不
all that gushy about them, to be honest with you. I knew nothing about kids' music. I knew nothing about teaching. I knew nothing about kids' music. I knew nothing about teaching. I knew nothing about anything. You know, I had hair, I had attitude. I weighed 98 pounds. Off I went to Langley and I started teaching. I was hippy-dippy. I had really no philosophy at all about teaching.
说实话，我对他们并不那么热情。我对儿童音乐一无所知。我对教学一无所知。我对儿童音乐一无所知。我对教学一无所知。我对任何事情都一无所知。你知道，我有头发，我有态度。我体重98磅。我去了兰利，开始教书。我是嬉皮士。我真的没有任何关于教学的哲学。
I can't really say I thought about it a lot. I had a lot of ideas about music, but certainly not about teaching. You know, for me, I mean, I've been playing in bands since I was like 11 or 12 years old, and it wasn't like anyone he taught us. It wasn't even like anybody said, oh this is the way you do it or that's the way you do it. We just sort of did it and I've been doing music like that since I was a little kid. So when I went into teaching music it never occurred to me that I was going to teach anybody how to read notes or that
我真的不能说我考虑过很多。我对音乐有很多想法，但肯定不是关于教学。你知道，对我来说，我的意思是，我从11或12岁起就在乐队里演奏，并不是有人教我们。甚至没有人说，哦，这是你做的方法，或者那是你做的方法。我们只是做了，我从小就一直在那样做音乐。所以当我开始教音乐时，我从来没想过我要教任何人如何读谱，或者
I was going to teach anybody how to pass a test. to teach anybody how to pass a test. The only thing I ever tried to teach children is really, it's just to fall in love with making music. That was always my goal. I just thought songs I knew, and I was very into David Bowie in those days. I was very into Iggy Pop. I was into Phil's old Phil Spector Records, Brian Wilson, and it wasn't until much later that I realized that songs were thematic. You know, I had gotten a teaching job originally because I was with my girlfriend and she was
我要教任何人如何通过考试。我教给孩子们的唯一一件事，真的，只是爱上制作音乐。那一直是我的目标。我只是想到了我知道的歌，而且我当时非常迷大卫·鲍伊。我非常迷伊基·波普。我迷菲尔·斯佩克特的旧唱片，布莱恩·威尔逊，直到很久以后我才意识到歌曲是有主题的。你知道，我最初得到这份教职是因为我和我的女朋友在一起，她
having a baby and I needed a day job. And by the time I got this job, we were breaking up. And I think that in the back of my mind, you know, I was feeling like a little bit lost. Contrary to what people think, a lot of kids aren't that happy. They all have troubles, they've got problems at home, they can feel lonely, they can feel isolated, and the music can conjure up that feeling into them. Now whether or not they completely
怀孕了，我需要一份日间工作。当我得到这份工作时，我们正在分手。我想在我的潜意识里，你知道，我感觉有点迷茫。与人们认为的相反，很多孩子并不那么快乐。他们都有烦恼，他们在家里有问题，他们会感到孤独，他们会感到孤立，音乐可以唤起他们那种感觉。现在，无论他们是否完全
literally understand the words, I'm not sure if she's that so important. I don't think Sheila, when she was singing Desperado, really knew what a lot of those references were about, but she certainly captured the feeling of the song. Desperado, why don't you bring to your senses, Give it a drawing thing to us So long now We're a hard one But I know that you got your reasons This thing's at our place the ear, the hurt you so how.
字面意思上理解歌词，我不确定这是否那么重要。我不认为希拉在唱《Desperado》时，真的知道那些参考资料是什么意思，但她肯定捕捉到了这首歌的感觉。《Desperado》，为什么你不清醒一点，把它画给我们，太久了，我们很难，但我知道你有你的理由，这东西在我们这里，伤害你，怎么。
When I heard other school choirs and things, we sounded so different and so weird, you know, that I thought, oh well, we can't be any good. I mean, listen to all those people. They really know how to sing. So I never thought of it in terms of it was special because it was good. I also thought of it in terms of if it was special because it was good. I also thought of it in terms of if it was special because it was different. Oftentimes I would have 16, 90 kids in my class, and there'd be all over the place because there was no room and we'd have instruments.
当我听到其他学校合唱团之类的东西时，我们听起来太不同、太怪异了，你知道，所以我心想，哦，好吧，我们肯定好不到哪去。我的意思是，听听那些人。他们真的知道怎么唱歌。所以我从来没想过它很特别，因为它很好。我也想过如果它很特别，是因为它很好。我也想过如果它很特别，是因为它与众不同。我经常在课堂上有60到90个孩子，他们到处都是，因为没有空间，我们有乐器。
We had no equipment, so I brought in all the equipment from my band, which were huge martial amplifiers and bass guitars and all kinds of things. The kids of course really liked that. So there wasn't much room, and kids were practically on top of one another, and I just sort of arranged them according to height. And that was it. I always felt like with my music teaching, that I always wasn't outside of music teaching that I always was an outsider music teacher.
我们没有设备，所以我从我的乐队带来了所有的设备，那是巨大的马歇尔放大器和低音吉他以及各种各样的东西。孩子们当然非常喜欢。所以没有多少空间，孩子们几乎叠在一起，我只是根据身高安排他们。就是这样。我一直觉得我的音乐教学，我一直是一个局外人音乐老师。
You know, I mean, I never really participated in a lot of the music teaching events and all that kind of stuff. I was always like a little island unto myself. You know, people always use this term like thinking outside the box and all that, but I think for me, I didn't even know there was a box, you know? I mean, it does have the sort of children of the corn, yeah. Yeah, it does have that feeling. Well, I think we were kind of like a little cult, you know. So it became kind of a kind of an underground hit in New York. Tony Visconti, who was David Bowie's producer, had heard it.
你知道，我的意思是，我从来没有真正参加过很多音乐教学活动之类的东西。我一直像是一个与世隔绝的小岛。你知道，人们总是用“跳出框框思考”之类的词，但我认为对我来说，我甚至不知道有一个框框，你知道？我的意思是，它确实有那种《玉米田的小孩》的感觉，是的。是的，它确实有那种感觉。好吧，我想我们有点像一个小邪教，你知道。所以它在纽约变成了一种地下热门。大卫·鲍伊的制作人托尼·维斯康蒂听到了它。
And I think he thought it was a new wave band from New Jersey. And he couldn't quite believe it was a bunch of little kids from some farm country in Canada. You've been a major great. And the papers want to know who should you be. Yeah, I have students that still do music to this day. They're always in touch with me. I jammed with some of them once in a while. I felt that the whole success of this was a really vindicating kind of experience. It made me feel really like, wow, I can't do something. So it was great. I mean, you know, I'd always taught my students in a really positive way.
我想他以为这是一支来自新泽西的新浪潮乐队。他简直不敢相信这是一群来自加拿大农场乡村的小孩子。你一直很棒。报纸想知道你是谁。是的，我有学生至今还在做音乐。他们总是和我保持联系。我偶尔会和他们中的一些人即兴演奏。我觉得这一切的成功是一种非常平反的经历。它让我感觉真的，哇，我能做点什么。所以这很棒。我的意思是，你知道，我一直以一种非常积极的方式教我的学生。
And then when somebody suddenly is positive about what you're doing like that, it gives you a great feeling. You're mine, you're small, and you're mine, you're tall, I like your mind. You're so good to me, I'm coming for you. You take my hand and give you one, this hand and I give it in a bedroom. You're so good to me. Our own Katie Mingle talked to Hans Finger of the Langley School music project in 2010 for the show Resound, produced by the Third Coast International Audio Festival. If you want to hear innovative documentaries from all over the world, you must subscribe to the Resound Podcast.
然后当有人突然对你正在做的事情持积极态度时，这会给你一种很棒的感觉。你是我的，你很小，你是我的，你很高，我喜欢你的思想。你对我太好了，我为你而来。你牵着我的手，给我一个，这只手，我把它放在卧室里。你对我太好了。我们自己的凯蒂·明格尔在2010年为Resound节目采访了兰利学校音乐项目的汉斯·芬格，该节目由第三海岸国际音频节制作。如果你想听到来自世界各地的创新纪录片，你必须订阅Resound播客。
And here are some fun facts. I worked on Resound at Third Coast for three years, and during that time, I hired Delaney Hall as an intern in 2006. It was her first radio job. And then when I left, Delaney took over and she hired Katie Mingle, who eventually took over the show herself. Now, we don't work here. So if you like us, you'll take a resound.
这里有一些有趣的事实。我在第三海岸的Resound工作了三年，在那期间，我在2006年雇佣了德莱尼·霍尔作为实习生。那是她的第一份广播工作。然后当我离开时，德莱尼接手了，她雇佣了凯蒂·明格尔，后者最终自己接管了节目。现在，我们不在这里工作了。所以如果你喜欢我们，你会订阅Resound。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Sean Cole, Emmett Fitzgerald, and Katie Mingle, mixed in tech production by Sharif Yusif, music by Sean Rial. This is the first time we've ever seen a new album of the year. It's a new album, and it's a new album. It's a new album, and it's a new album. It's a new album, and it's a new album. It's a new album, and it's a new album. It's a new album, and it's a new album. It's a new album. It's a new album. on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of
《99% Invisible》本周由肖恩·科尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德和凯蒂·明格尔制作，由谢里夫·尤西夫进行混音和技术制作，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。这是我们第一次看到年度新专辑。这是一张新专辑，这是一张新专辑。这是一张新专辑，这是一张新专辑。这是一张新专辑，这是一张新专辑。这是一张新专辑，这是一张新专辑。这是一张新专辑，这是一张新专辑。这是一张新专辑，这是一张新专辑。这是一张新专辑。这是一张新专辑。在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的Radio Row。99% Invisible是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个极其独立的集体，
the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. You can find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you're thinking, I need more 99PI in my life, we have old episodes and new articles about design every couple of days on our website. It's 99PI.O. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
汇集了所有播客中最具创新性的节目。你可以在radiotopia.fm找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也可以。但如果你在想，我的生活中需要更多的99PI，我们的网站上每隔几天就有旧剧集和关于设计的新文章。网址是99PI.org。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。